les britanniques ont pris une décision
très claire de prendre un chemin
différent et de ce résultat
je pense que le pays a besoin d'un
nouveau leader pour prendre ces
directions
je ferai tout ce que je peux en tant que
premier ministre pour stabiliser le
navire au cours des prochaines semaines
et des prochains mois mais je ne pense
pas que ce serait bien pour moi
d'essayer d'être le capitaine qui
dirigent notre pays vers sa prochaine
destination de neige 51,9 % des voix le
out l'emportent la grande bretagne ne
fera bientôt plus partie de l'union
européenne les électeurs se sont rendus
massivement aux urnes un verdict
implacable un choc pour les britanniques
à une déflagration pour l'europe europe
hebdo spécial break site nous allons
analyser ce résultat ses conséquences
sur le royaume uni sur l'europe sur
notre économie est bien entendu sur la
france et pour en débattre je reçois
emmanuel maurel vous êtes député
européen membre du groupe socialiste
bienvenue pour jour philippe juvin vous
est également membre du parlement
européen cette fois ci dans le groupe
ppe on est républicain français je
bienvenue à vous il verte uncini vous
êtes le directeur de l'institut notre
europe
bienvenue bonjour et en face de vous
christopher chanterai représentants du
parti conservateur britannique ici à
paris vous êtes par ailleurs le
président de l'association british
community committee en france bienvenue
à vous messieurs alors cette sortie
annoncée de la grande bretagne de
l'union européenne est ce que c'est une
bonne nouvelle est ce que ça permet une
clarification finalement ou est ce que
c'est une catastrophe ils vertes ont
signé c'est une amputation pour l'union
européenne
ça va être douloureux ça va se passer
pas forcément en douceur si on regarde
le monde c'est quand même un membre très
important de l'union qui sort à un
moment où on aurait plutôt besoin
d'union pour peser parce que nous sommes
7 % de la population mondiale va bientôt
6 504 millions et bientôt 6 1 piscine
dans les britanniques nous quitte et qui
a des défis et compris à nos portes des
dangers donc c'est une amputation
c'est plutôt négatif alors ça sera vue
positivement parce qu'ils disent que
après tout il y avait une forme de
gangrène britannique et qui vaut mieux
couper un pays trop a dit
liste trop atlantiste trop libérale
peut-être et que ça ira mieux quand on
aura coupé et au fond quand on aura pris
acte du fait que la greffe c'est si vrai
que d'ailleurs deux ans après leur
entrée ils organisaient déjà un
référendum mais qui avait été à l'époque
gagné par le wii par le rumen à 67 ans
et que vous êtes d'accord
christopher champions c'est moi je vais
pas être d'accord
je n'avais pas envie de traiter mon pays
dit long de deux membres d'un gang
rennais c'est vrai que là alors ces
questions de grève qui n'a pas pris je
pense que le public britannique est sous
informé sur les questions de l'europe et
c'est notamment à cause de la mauvaise
qualité des titres de la presse
quotidienne tableau 1 4 grands titres
qui sont lus par des millions de
personnes et qui nuisent qui ne disent
jamais c'est un politique presque in qui
ne disent jamais sur la presse sans
vouloir faire très protégé ici mes
confrères quand on voit aussi que la
classe politique a repris les mêmes
arguments
la classe politique a repris vie un peu
les mêmes arguments et la campagne a été
vraiment désolante jean oui pour nous
c'est une catastrophe c'est quelque
chose qu'il ne fallait il fallait pas
combien qu'on en arrive là c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle incontestablement je
pense qu'on est nombreux à être triste
c'est pas non plus une catastrophe je
pense pas être excessif la vraie
difficulté pour nous européens je me
place du côté des européens
c'est le risque de délitement on sort
quand même d'une situation de poly crise
vous avez la crise de l'euro avec la
grèce c'était quand même déjà très
inquiétant
la crise dite des réfugiés haut débit
grand on en est pas sorti une
radicalisation politique de l'europe de
l'est on voit ce qui se passe en hongrie
en pologne
hélas le break site franchement ça donne
l'impression d'une europe qui est en
grand danger
la grèce sortent finalement un an après
c'est la grande bretagne
oui enfin d'ailleurs c'est assez cocasse
de voir qu'il ya ceux qui pleurnichent
aujourd'hui c'est les mêmes qui voulait
jeter dehors la grèce il ya quelques il
ya quelques mois enfin moi je peux
importe mais ce qui est vrai en tout cas
c'est que l'europe est en crise mais on
n'a pas attendu le break site pour le
savoir peut-être que justement le brésil
aura une vertu pour nous européens c'est
que c'est une opportunité de changer
complètement la construction européenne
et y'a de quoi faire parce que la vérité
c'est que il faudra analyser jeu
peut-être on le fera ici les les raisons
exactes de la sortie de
l'avenir et annick parce qu'il ya plein
de causes y compris des choses
troublantes
toutes les consultations sur l'europe
des montres qui a des fractures
fractures territoriales entre les
métropoles et les zones périurbaines
fracture de classe aussi bas les
ouvriers évidemment ils votent plus pour
le mais c'est intéressant de voir ça
c'est comme un toute l'europe et de ce
point de vue là il ya quand même
l'europe fait pas envie quoi voilà les
musées valeur a très envie de le savoir
non mais en fait est ce une catastrophe
l'a d'abord si on se place d'un point de
vue britannique moi je pense que c'est
un suicide de la grande bretagne parce
qu'on ne peut pas imaginer qu'un pays de
quelques dizaines de millions
d'habitants puisse durablement peser sur
les affaires du monde
donc il ya un vrai vraie question pour
les britanniques c'est qu'ils se sont
isolés d'un véhicule de puissance qu'est
l'union européenne et c'est leur
problème
et ça c'est le deuxième point ça reste
quand même plus leurs problèmes que le
nôtre alors nous maintenant que de vous
nous faire moi je pense qu'il ya
peut-être une chose à faire c'est
effectivement d'analyser les raisons
pour lesquelles l'opinion publique
britannique a voulu ainsi sortir pour
éviter que ça nous arrive à en tirer les
conséquences aussi pour nous mêmes alors
justement un vendredi matin après
l'annoncé officielle des résultats le
royaume uni se réveille groggy et entre
dans une ère d'incertitude
retour sur ce séisme du break site et
ses conséquences sur la scène politique
anglaise c'est marie brémaud qui nous en
parle le soleil s'est levé ce matin sur
la capitale anglaise mais l'avenir c'est
d'un coup assombri pour l'actuel premier
ministre britannique david cameron et
des faits il avait jeté toutes ses
forces dans le camp du in pour le
maintien du royaume uni dans l'union
européenne
ce n'est pas une décision que j'ai prise
à la légère mais je crois que c'est dans
l'intérêt national d'avoir une période
de stabilité avant la nomination d'un
nouveau leader qui est nécessaire le
leader du parti conservateur tir dès à
présent les conséquences du scrutin ou
51 9 % des électeurs ont voté pour le
bric site
david cameron annonce sa démission même
s'il assurera une transition jusqu en
octobre et la tenue d'un congrès du
parti conservateur dans le camp adverse
on exulte
même si boris johnson le bouillonnant
chef de file des partisans du bric sic
est accueilli devant chez lui par des
londoniens en colère
l'ancien maire de londres espère bien
enfoncer la porte du 10 downing street
et il commence donc à modérer son
discours après ce vote pour sortir de
l'union européenne il est vital
d'insister sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas
de précipitation à voir et comme l'a dit
le premier ministre
rien ne va changer sur le court terme
l'indépendance du royaume uni il en
rêvait et à l'issue de ce référendum
nigel farrage sort clairement renforcé
connu pour ses actions chocs et ses
propos xénophobes
le leader du parti europhobe ukip ne
compte pas s'arrêter là
j'espère que nous avons cassé la
première brique du mur j'espère que ce
sera la première étape vers une europe
des états souverains
alors qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant
à la caisse qui se passe ensuite et bien
17 millions de personnes ont dit que
nous devons quitter l'union européenne
nous avons maintenant besoin d'un
gouvernement de présenter un
gouvernement de brigitte car les
électeurs en choisissant le camp du out
ont également envoyé un message à leurs
dirigeants politiques
un divorce sans doute entre les classes
populaires et l'élite britannique
est-ce qu'il faut un gouvernement de
break site aujourd'hui en grande
bretagne si on n' à geoffroy jouit pas
ce que lui hier des ambitions
personnelles il se voit j'imagine
partenaires à en coédition you keep et
est parti conservateur don qu'il se voit
député premier ministre c'est le poste
qui avait occupé
le leader des libéraux démocrates nick
clegg dans le gouvernement de 2010 c'est
clair monsieur était ambitieux mais
c'est pas forcément une solution c'est
pas une bonne solution il faut il faut
arrêter de rades de se raconter des
histoires un peu mythomane
il faut maintenant elle pragmatique et
voir comment on peut régler comment on
peut mettre en oeuvre la décision prise
par le peuple
hier et ce n'est pas un ce n'est pas une
continuation de la campagne c'est pas ça
qui va le faire s'il faut il faut quand
vous entendez parler vraiment on n'est
pas pressé après tout prenons le temps
c'est complètement sa cette libération
va lancer une procédure de divorce il
faut dire que ce soit les britanniques
qui envoie une lettre non pas au père
noël mon seuil européen activer
l'article
en décembre il me tardait à l'envoyer
surtout si cameron dit que ça sera
peut-être son successeur qui va qui va
faire ça après le congrès des conserves
à simplement parce que pour des raisons
domestiques comme pour des raisons
européenne il faudrait quand même passer
à l'action
du point de vue britannique parce que
quand on lance une procédure de divorce
même dans la vie courante on sait bien
que le jugement va intervenir après
quelques temps parfait il faut quand
même qu'ils aient des changements
concrets ces parts ont fait chambre à
part éventuellement en tout cas on
déménage enfin on ne fait pas comme
avant imaginez que le peuple britannique
qui a gagné 52 48 c'est quand même pas
tout le peuple contre toutes les élites
n'ya pas 48% des littoraux royaume uni
va exiger de voir des changements
concrets rapidement réduisions à vis de
l'union européenne il ya le respect
évidemment de ce verdict
l'union européenne ce n'est pas l'union
soviétique c'est pas une prison des
peuples
les britanniques veulent sortir mais
enfin mais faudrait pas non plus que ça
prenne cinq ou huit ans parce qu'il ya
d'autres choses à faire qui sait vous
qui sont bien plusieurs j'enfile des
budgets notamment dans notre voisinage à
traiter absolument dehors c'est dehors
ils sont clairs ils ont décidé de rester
dehors il faut qu'ils y restent et que
ça soit fait vite parce qu'en fait
juridiquement l'article 50 qui est
l'article qui gouverne le divorce dit la
chose suivante le premier ministre en
l'occurrence de la grande bretagne va
faire savoir au conseil
l'ontt et de quitter et ils ont deux ans
pour trouver les termes du divorce
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des règles des
fonctionnaires britanniques par exemple
qui travaillent dans ces institutions
européennes que fait on des accords en
cours etc etc et ces deux ans ces deux
ans maximum mais qui peuvent être
mauvais si tous les états sont d'accord
la difficulté c'est que par exemple je
ne vous donne que cet exemple dans un an
c'est la grande bretagne qui préside au
1er juillet dénoncée il serait
inimaginable qu'on sait la présidence
tournante tous les six moyens un pays
gouverne on va dire de dirige préside
l'union et le 1er juillet 2017 c'est la
grande bretagne
il est inimaginable que la procédure de
divorce dur tellement que dans un an on
se retrouve avec la grande bretagne qui
gouvernent qui préside l'union donc il
faut que les choses aillent vite
ça veut dire que la grande bretagne doit
abandonner sa présidente tournante bien
sûr emma morel moussa je crois qu'il n'y
a pas de débat là dessus enfin je vous
ai dit qu il y aura sûrement un débat
jamais politiquement il est totalement
inconcevable que la grande-bretagne
préside aux destinées de l'union pendant
six mois alors même qu'elle a décidé de
la cité d'ailleurs il y aura pas que le
problème des fonctionnaires qui se pose
à moi c'est pas forcément pressés mais
prenons l'exemple tout bête du parlement
européen 72 députés britanniques donc
des gens qui peut faire basculer une
majorité sur un texte
imaginons peut toujours rêver que la
droite et la gauche la france et
l'allemagne se mettent d'accord sur
quelque chose qui valait dans le sens
dans le progrès pour européen disons par
exemple taxe sur les transactions
financières on décide d'accélérer et
imaginer qu'il est maudit que des
britanniques qu'ils fassent échouer
ça va poser comme britannique même si
c'est même si évidemment on a peur
gouvernement de brigitte je ne sais pas
je note et je trouve que c'est bien
c'est heureux que david cameron qu'après
une responsabilité historique
c'est celle de ce référendum hyper il
s'en va je trouve que c'est bien en ce
moment pour nous ce qu'on est plus
habitué au référendum de responsabilité
de ce point de vue là c'est pas mal je
note aussi là par contre ça me met
plutôt en colère que boris johnson que
des arguments totalement démago jusqu'à
hier soir
depuis ce matin ils essaient de rentrer
dans le costume de l'homme politique
respectable et nous fera pas oublier
toutes les horreurs qu'il a raconté
pendant deux mois
alors justement à ce propos gabriel d'y
marquer une députée européenne et qui
n'est membre de la gauche européenne
unie donc l'extrême gauche a réagi ce
matin à propos du jeu politique de
cameron dans les coûteux david cameron
est responsable de cette réaction avec
ce genre de référendum
il a détourné des instruments
démocratiques comme le référendum pour
une lutte politique interne dans son
parti et son gouvernement
il est responsable
cette affaire centre est il est
responsable avec cameron il a joué avec
le feu
il a un peu joué avec le feu c'est vrai
2 pour nous vous nous pour beaucoup de
nous conservateurs on pense que le roi
munich ne devrait pas recourir au
référendum c'est une
c'est une démocratie parlementaire ça
devrait suffire surtout pour les
questions très compliquées comme
l'adhésion ou le maintien ou la sortie
du de l'union européenne on devrait pas
à utiliser le référendum
la regrettée si vous voulez le monde
nombreux à penser qu'il inscrit dans la
constitution où on pourrait ne pas le
faire gilberte ainsi nos prix du risque
si vous partez pas à mon avis à une
double erreur encore bien plus grave
stratégique
la première qui a été de dire écoutez de
bruxelles nous gouvernent ça ne peut
plus durer
pousse à nouveau ouvert franchement vous
pouvez pas dire que ça qui ont gouverné
pas non plus non mais franchement
bruxelles a un peu gouverner la city
dans la dernière période ce qui était
pas plus mal ce qui a déplu à certaines
personnes dans la city certes mais enfin
eu un discours de fierté nationale
aurait consisté à dire nous sommes le
royaume uni de grande bretagne et
d'irlande du nord
bruxelles nous embête évidemment un peu
enfin on va quand même défendre nos
intérêts à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne
il a commencé par laisser croire que
tous les malheurs du royaume uni
viennent de bruxelles premièrement ça
c'est quand même assez fâcheux et
deuxièmement en laissé entendre que
d'ailleurs peut-être la sortie était une
option tout à fait raisonnable et
pendant trois ans il a dit à l'opinion
publique britannique et ça ça va au delà
des tabloïds qui racontent ce qu'ils
racontent depuis des décennies il a dit
pas écouté l'union européenne je suis ni
pour ni contre bien au contraire on
verra bien et dans la dernière ligne
droite il arrache un texte qui n'a
pratiquement joué aucun rôle en panne et
il henri darras conseil européen février
pour obtenir en fait dans un contexte
dans un contexte qui compte évidemment
et qui est beaucoup plus difficile à la
fois pour l'union européenne qui donne
une très mauvaise image depuis plusieurs
années qu'ils se déchirent dont les
peuples d'ailleurs se déchirent entre
eux mais aussi dans un contexte
difficile du point de vue britannique
parce qu'il ya quand même une crise
économique qui en financière très grave
partout en europe dans le monde y en ait
au royaume uni et donc arrogé des élites
pas seulement bruxelloise des élites
politiques financières londoniennes
qui s'est exprimé hier il va y avoir un
autre problème qui va se poser c'est que
les irlandais du nord et les écossais se
sont prononcés e pour le maintien je
rappelle que l'irlande du nord a voté à
56 % pour le maintien l'europhile
écossais l'a62 là on voit quand même
qu'il ya des réactions qui vont pousser
en fait à des référendums y compris en
irlande y compris en écosse sur
l'indépendance qui ont demandé
typiquement être rallier ensuite à
l'europe
est ce que cameron va être celui qui
aura aussi dissous l'union jack
il va coûter cameron quand il dans ses
premières années de premier ministre
était très critique sur l'europe et il a
essayé de muter en saint-georges
défendant la grande bretagne en europe
dans les dernières semaines donc ça ne
pouvait pas marcher boris johnson était
maire d'une commune d'une grande ville
une capitale européenne dont il de
lancer la capitale européenne que nous
sommes européens
il lui se mue en rappelant qu'il a été
journaliste et qui a été chargé des
affaires européennes se faire et et
fonctionnaires européens et lui ce mur
nantis europe et enfin on voit bien
qu'on est dans un jeu de dupes le plus
total alors maintenant quelles vont être
les conséquences de sa bien ça signifie
qu'on pratique cameron restera dans
l'histoire comme celui qui a sorti la
grande bretagne et qu'il a isolé et qui
fait courir la grande à la
grande-bretagne à sa sauce
ces deux grandes nations européennes le
risque simplement de dissolution avec
peut-être la disparition de l'ecosse
avec peut-être le détachement de
l'irlande parce que la question de la
frontière entre la république d'irlande
et la grande bretagne de nouveau se pose
alors qu'elles étaient résolus puis
nombreuses années pas moins d'eau que
dans l'histoire je ne suis pas certain
qu'avec david cameron restent eux
restera un grand premier ministre c'est
possible en même temps il faut pas non
plus être hypocrite cameron fait ce que
font tous les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens dans son propre
pays et critique les décisions qu'il a
contribué à négocier quand il est à
bruxelles a relu est un spécialiste mais
les autres valent pas mieux de ce point
de vue là et c'est d'ailleurs tout le
problème du débat européen
c'est que vous avez des souvent des
dirigeants politiques qui hurlent par
rapport à ce que bruxelles a décidé
alors même que ce que bruxelles décident
ça n'est rien d'autre que le compromis
que eux ont voulu
parfois même il n'est pas fier pour être
clair en fait les chefs d'état de
gouvernement siègent dans les conseils
une décision européenne
briser la vie de la vie parlementaire on
peut vous dire que souvent d'ailleurs on
arrive à se mettre d'accord au parlement
mais ça bloque avec le conseil chef
d'état gouvernement grand teint il est
pire qu on sait combien c'est une crise
et il est pire que les autres parce
qu'il est allé jusqu'à l'enfer d'un
exactement deuxièmement ce référendum
quand même c'est parce que c'est
peut-être pas dont la en effet dans la
tradition constitionnel anglaise mais je
voudrais pas non plus que comme à chaque
fois qu'il ya un référendum sur l'europe
on est toutes ses tirades un peu éplorée
sur lala référendum c'est pas bien
demander son avis au peuple c'est pas
bien parce que c'est trop complexe
la vérité quand même c'est que depuis
plus de dix ans à chaque fois qu'on
demande leur avis à n'importe quel
peuple européen il soit
traditionnellement europhile ou
europhobes et ça il dit non une campagne
mensongère
on s'en fout la réalité c'est qu'il dit
non tout le temps oui mais pourtant les
néerlandais ont dit non sur l'accord
avec l'ukraine franchement la campagne
n'était pas né quand c'est sur le
terrain du plan b qui n'a pas de plan b
c'est à moi c'est pas vrai la campagne
sur le terrain je me souviens c'est une
campagne très citoyen tout le monde
s'était approprié le texte donc la
vérité quand le traité constitutionnel
européen
voilà notre jeu et je peux vous dire que
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on ait une
campagne pour expliquer le tfc j'ai un
traité par dont le traité budgétaire qui
aujourd'hui vit complètement les mains
des états membres et qui interdit toute
flexibilité budgétaire au moment où il
ya besoin de relance ça c'est la
deuxième chose vraiment des débats mais
j'aime vraiment mais un manque de
démocratie vont lourdement france avait
la trouille pas forcément sur
l'appartenance à l'union ça je pensais
pas nécessaire mais sur les prochains
traité je le crois et le tc juste aurait
mérité puisque hollande n'a pas
renégocié serait mérité un débat public
c'est bien le problème
troisième chose rapidement les causes
vous souvenez que le principal argument
quand il ya eu le référendum de
l'indépendance en écosse principal
argument des onglets c'est à dire si
vous votez d'indépendance vous sortez
l'union voilà ça ce traitement a versé
est évidemment ces facteurs de
déflagrations ça le royaume n'est plus
très unie et bercy non sur la femme je
suis assez d'accord ça peut être eu une
option dont certains pays l'irlande
c'est même obligatoire nokia des
transferts marque de souveraineté en
france le conseil qu'officiel pour le
pacte budgétaire avait dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de transfert de souveraineté
dont sa n'impliquait pas forcément un
référendum je signe a quand même au
passage que le treut des consignes
européen qui avait été rejeté par
référendum en france et aux pays bas
avait été votée par référendum en
espagne et au et au luxembourg
à la différence quand ont recours au
référendum européen sait s'il s'agit de
référendum d'appartenance comme hier on
peut donner satisfaction au peuple
problème les britanniques veulent sortir
ils vont sortir si ce sont des
référendums d'approfondissement les
danois par exemple n'ont pas voulu
rentrer dans l'euro sont pas rentrés
dans l'euro le problème c'est les
référendums de gouvernance type traité
de lisbonne traité constitutionnel
européen les règles communes
même chose le référendum néerlandais sur
l'accord d'association ukraine
l'accord d'association ue ukraine c'est
pour tout lieu et là on se retrouve
coincé parce qu'un peuple se fussent
après un référendum ne peut pas un vent
imposer sa volonté aux vingt-sept autres
le déni de démocratie parfois en avril
et la jeune et pour les femmes s'il ya
un coup de folie il faut il mettre un s
à la fin dans le déni de démocratie on
ne peut pas parce qu'on a voté non en
france en 2005 par exemple continuer à
dire on n'a pas respecté notre mans mais
les autres il faut bien respecter ce
qu'il en sait pas ce que l'europe on la
construit à plusieurs ou alors on fait
bande à part comme les britanniques
comme ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui alors
bien entendu la réaction des marchés ne
s'est pas fait attendre dégringolade des
monnaies de la livre de l'euro les
bourses mondiales dévissent
c'est un petit peu la panique les
explications d'eloïse grégoire est
encore sonné dans cette banque
personne n'avait anticipé la victoire du
out au référendum tout le monde croyait
que le maintien dans l'union européenne
allait l'emporter
et c'était vraiment un consensus au
niveau des investisseurs des marchés
financiers on a d'ailleurs cru à peu
près jusqu'à 2 heures du matin 3 heures
du matin que sa lettre le cap et l'autre
point c'est que le break site entraîne
une incertitude et on sait très bien que
la certitude est négatif pour les
marchés financiers pour l'investissement
dans l'économie réelle donc c'est
certainement la plus grosse
problématique à moyen terme
longue de choc et mondiale jusqu'au
japon la bourse de tokyo a perdu 7%
quant au dax lundi bourse de francfort a
été balayée par un vent de panique et a
chuté quasiment dès son ouverture de
-10%
c'est au tour de la bourse de paris de
plongée à 9h32 de près de 10% également
les différentes banques centrales ont
rapidement réagi en injectant des
liquidités pour rassurer les marchés
boursiers et canaliser les taux
d'intérêt c'est le cas de l'angleterre
ou de la suisse le meilleur moyen
d'endiguer la panique ce sera de 1
d'avoir une action des banques centrales
coordonnée et rapide c'est ce qui
commence à se mettre en place
progressivement
et le deuxième point c'est aussi de ne
plus avoir une incertitude politique
concernant la manière dont vont être
réglés la sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne la banque centrale
européenne véritable pompier financier
s'est dit prête à fournir 326 milliards
d'euros alors à la mi journée le cac 40
avait des fils davy ses parts dans deux
quasi 8% 8 42% à un petit peu plus de
4000 points là clairement la devise
enfin la livre est au plus bas depuis
1985 c'est quoi les risques pour
l'économie européenne c'est de revivre
2008 avec la chute de lehman brothers
soit on est encore dans un scénario bien
pire
philippe juvin a d'abord il ya un risque
pour l'économie britannique l'économie
britannique s'est 1%
ces 3 % du pib mondial c'est à dire en
fait une goutte d'eau et c'est surtout
grâce à l'union européenne un accès pour
les entreprises britanniques à un marché
de 550 millions d'habitants qui est
l'union européenne ce marché aujourd'hui
ne leur sera plus accessible
si ce n'est en payant des droits de
douane 1 d'après les droits de douane
pour être clair ils peuvent être remis
en place dès demain alors t'es d'min
nommé dans les mois qui viennent dans
les mois qui viennent de la même manière
en fait la grande bretagne va à terme
dans les mois qui viennent être traité
comme un pays tiers par l'union
européenne
c'est à dire par les partenaires de
l'union européenne par exemple nous
avons signé l'une l'union européenne a
signé un contrat d'association
commercial avec le canada avec la corée
du sud avec lesquels nous commerçons en
ayant aboli des droits de douane et bien
le canada et la corée risque
probablement de dire à la grande
bretagne
désormais nous vous traitons
différemment cno qui est un risque
d'abord pour l'économie britannique
d'accord il bertrand signé sur ce sujet
bon on lance la procédure de divorce
il faut la lancée et en parallèle il
faut négocier la suite c'est à dire une
forme de pacs et on ne sait pas encore
quel statut les britanniques auront pas
sûr s'il acceptait par exemple le statut
de membre de l'espace économique
européen
tu as tué la norvégienne par exemple ils
n'auraient pas ce genre de problème en
fait ils resteraient dans l'espace
économique européen
c'est ça qui doit négocier arrêté à la
suisse moi j'avais jamais parlé à des
responsables britanniques va édition
sort ans
on négociera de toute façon un statut à
la britannique paraît avec avec personne
d'autre mais un peu à la suisse mais en
mieux
si je puis dire la difficulté qu'ils
vont avoir c'est que quand on a accès au
marché unique européen
on doit accepter deux choses d'abord la
libre circulation des travailleurs
ça fait partie des quatre libertés or ça
a fait problème dans la campagne sur
l'immigration y compris européennes même
si l'essentiel d'immigration au royaume
uni n'est pas européenne en fait il y
avait un vrai problème notamment avec
d'immigration d'europe centrale ont
remis à charmer les polonais 2 deuxième
chose il faut payer le au budget
européen quand même la norvège p au but
et au budget européen
c'est le prix de l'accès au marché
unique et ça c'est problématique parce
que s'ils veulent vraiment rester dans
le marché unique pour ne pas connaître
ce que philippe juvin prédit alors il va
falloir qui continue à assumer deux
choses la libre circulation des
travailleurs et la contribution au
budget britannique qui ont visiblement
été problématique pendant la campagne
qui peuvent faire partie pour regarder
le détail des raisons pour lesquelles
une majorité courte des britanniques ont
voté pour la sortie vous avez raison
pardon mais toutefois il va y avoir une
première étape de divorce et ensuite
dans une seconde étape on va
éventuellement retisser des liens
et c'est d'ailleurs que ce que boris
johnson maintenant commence à expliquer
ces ne vous inquiétez pas nous avons
divorcé mais en réalité nous allons
continuer à faire appartement commun la
vérité ce n'est pas ça c'est que le
divorce a lieu nous allons nous séparer
nous n'allons plus habiter au même
endroit et peut être qu'ensuite nous
allons retisser des liens mais il va y
avoir une période intermédiaire ou la
grande bretagne va quand même être un
pays tiers ça va il va pas y avoir de
continuum entre l'arrêt des procédures
actuelles en fin des avantages actuels
dont bénéficie la grande bretagne et il
n'y aura pas un continuum immédiatement
avec de nouveaux accords ifa il faut la
rue cler du cac doit politiquement tant
que député du ppe nous explique
clairement les choses
nous sommes totalement défavorable à un
système qui consisterait à dire ah les
pauvres britannique c'est formidable ils
veulent sortir mais vous savez on va moi
non vous êtes devoir vous êtes dehors on
est à moitié de ça va être tout le débat
dans les mois à venir parce que jusqu'à
maintenant la grande bretagne était
dedans tout en étant un peu dehors
voilà deux là là là elle va être dehors
mais elle va continuer en tout cas
d'après ce que je comprends à vouloir
continuer à être dedans
la question elle est posée à nous
européens est ce qu on veut que ça soit
comme ça on est pas je suis pas sûr en
tout cas dans mon groupe politique le
groupe social démocrate il ya des débats
je suis pas sûr pour le veuille
alors sur lui il est vraiment trop la
ligne dehors comme les dix longueurs la
vérité c'est que là pour le coup il ya
un choix qui est fait je trouve ça
formidable que les britanniques votent
mais une fois que le verdict soit lié au
franc et donner le show il est légitime
pour ça c'est un choix donc à partir de
là où il ya un choix il faut assumer les
conséquences de ce choix sains pour ça
que johnson là franchement ne fait pas
honneur à sa enfin j'allais dire sa
réputation fait sa réputation n'est déjà
fait
c'est à dire que on peut pas à la fois
pendant pendant deux mois expliqué
qu'une fois qu'on sa sortie ce sera un
avenir radieux
et puis expliqué le lendemain que tout
compte fait on va négocier l'avenir
annuler
mais quelles conséquences pour
l'économie européenne est ce que le
risque c'est à l'heure où en fait la
reprise s'annonçait et on voyait fin
c'est le fameux ça va mieux françois
hollande aussi un petit peu
est ce que le risque en fait c'est de ne
pas retrouver la crise actuelle a connu
que c'est d'abord leur problème
ces chiffres en termes d'emploi
enfermerait pris un ris intellectuelle
simplement parlement européen j'ai
souvent vu que nos collègues
conservateurs britanniques en
particulier et c'est vrai pour les
socialistes aussi britannique avait une
liberté d'esprit dans l'appréhension de
la création de la loi européenne
là où il y avait des certitudes et des
choses un peu strict il apportait de
l'intelligence et de la fluidité ça ça
va nous manquer mais sur l'économie
honnêtement c'est d'abord le problème
britannique le risque peut-être
christopher chanterai c'est leur terme
d'emploi pour l'angleterre c'est vrai en
terme d'emploi d'abord le risque n'est
de l'incertitude
il ya eu le 24 juin l'annnonce de ce
matin mais après la saisie de ces camps
vont avoir lieu ces différentes étapes
on ne sait pas donc on sait pas les
droits de douane on ne sait pas combien
ni ni quand et il faut il faut reporter
que c'est dans quelques mois vous passez
ces relations moi je vois on en a parlé
on au sein de la commission commerce
international il faut pas faut tout
recommencer
de fait l'angleterre etc est signataire
de tous les accords de libre échange de
l'union mais va falloir tout détricoter
je sais pas sur 200 d'accords
commerciaux quatre factions
je sais mais j'ai je pense quand même
rinne d'un point de vue technique ça va
être un sacré casse tête le problème
c'est la volonté politique sinon on dit
écoutez les amis mais je pense que les
grands les britanniques vont demander à
avoir le même statut que la norvège
écoute independence day ça va être
indépendante mais c'est quand même
l'indépendance dans l'interdépendance
comme on disait jadis 16% du pib de
l'union européenne
quand même une nécessité pour les
partenaires économiques et politiques de
l'union du royaume uni de composer alors
avec une situation de faiblesse pour le
royaume-uni désormais puisqu'il a décidé
de sortir maman la vie avec pas mal de
friction entre les états membres et y
compris au sein des groupes du parlement
européen il y aura des good cop
il y aura des bad cop je pense qu'en
france ça sera plutôt les bad cop mais
il y aura quand même des partisans d'une
solution à la mab y compris dans la
continuité que vous semblez rejeté
faudra regarder notamment du côté des
néerlandais des allemands des alliés
traditionnels des polonais ils feront
peser le pour et le contre y compris en
termes économiques et financières de
l'impact d'une interdépendance sèche du
royaume uni qui certes fera du tort aura
aimé mais en remet aussi ferait du tort
à la bonhomie
sinon on va vous remercier à yves
bertoncini parce que vous devez nous
quitter merci à vous de nous avoir
éclairé nous on continue bien entendu
parce que le coup de semonce fut
également pour l'union européenne
une nouvelle ère s'ouvre désormais pour
les 27 pays qui la composent donc quel
calendrier et quelle stratégie
sandra sert qu'à nous explique avec la
victoire du breakbeat
c'est un véritable casse-tête
institutionnel qui démarre le président
du parlement européen
préoccupée par le sort de l'euro
souhaite que les négociations débutent
vite
c'est un moment difficile pour tout le
monde au sein de l'union européenne et
pour le royaume uni bien sûr tribute au
niveau du parlement européen
nous sommes prêts à contribuer par tous
les moyens
un processus que l'on veut constructif
la plupart des membres du parlement
européen pour souligner que la stabilité
s'impose l'article 50 baptisée clause de
retrait est bien prévu depuis 2009 et le
traité de lisbonne mais il reste floue
sur les modalités
le royaume uni doit maintenant notifier
au conseil européen son intention de
partir mais rien ne l'obligé à le faire
tout de suite
je veux aussi vous assurer qu'il n'y
aura pas de vide juridique jusqu'à ce
que le royaume uni qui te formellement
l'union européenne les lois de lieux
continueront à s'appliquer à l'intérieur
du royaume uni aussi bien en matière de
droit que de devoir une fois la
procédure lancée londres et bruxelles
auront deux ans maximum pour négocier
mais cela pourra prendre beaucoup plus
de temps car l'accord doit être approuvé
par le parlement et le conseil européens
la question qui se posera alors quelle
sera la place du royaume uni par rapport
à ses partenaires
tout est envisageable imiter l'islande
et la norvège
en rejoignant l'espace économique
européen mais avec l'obligation
d'accepter la libre circulation des
personnes
c'est à dire ce que les partisans du
brésil veulent éviter ou se calquer sur
le modèle suisse avec une série
d'accords bilatéraux avec l'union
européenne ou sur celui de la turquie
avec une union douanière
alors nous accueillons pascale joannin
directrice générale de la fondation
robert schuman pascal janin première
question deux ans pour renégocier donc
200 accords commerciaux 80 mille pages
de loi communautaire l'a clairement
c'est un travail de titan vous y croyez
ou pas ce calendrier
c'est le minimum ouais c'est pas
forcément deux ans ça peut durer plus
longtemps
donc de fait c'est possible c'est
possible ça dépend de mon père à 5 ans
jusqu'à 6 en reste là las de courir à
partir du moment où les angles les
britanniques vont officiellement faire
leurs demandes de retrait ont cru
comprendre que c'étaient pas avant que
le nouveau premier ministre désigné
c'est à dire au congrès du parti
conservateur en octobre mais rien ne dit
que le premier jour où le premier
ministre est
britanniques et aux lots zhang strict il
envoie sa lettre il peut très bien voyez
plus tard or après son agression pauline
un ca à partir de ce moment là que la
demande court donc et que les lélés
bruxelles prend acte en effet de la
demande de retrait officiel qui a été
fait donc déjà c'est pas avant le mois
d'octobre on veut dire et sous la
pression politique
il peut très bien aussi commencé le
processus de la semaine prochaine non
bien sûr oui on va peut-être pas
attendre octobre non le problème la
période d'incertitude il faudrait
mexique et on est moins bons donnent une
image déjà qu'on a souvent tendance à
donner une image juridico technocratique
aux questions européennes
flash bis q c'est vraiment une question
politique donc on va pas commencer à
finasser a détaillé tel machin à partir
d'où ils ont fait un choix il faut
l'assumer faut que l'union européenne
elle aille de l'avant parce que ça veut
dire
ginette même la situation s'ils votent
le bric site business as usual tient
alors on va mettre tous les fous non
merci
or les droits de vote emmanuel maurel
des parlementaires
on empêche cameron devenir ce mardi et
ce mercredi en empêcher j'ai vu qu'un
collègue alain lamassoure depuis du
groupe philippe juvin disait à partir de
la semaine prochaine il ya plus de
droits de vote pour les députés
européens britanniques c'est quand même
un débat qu'on va avoir très vite ça
nous fait mal parce que comme le disait
philippe gilbert à l'instant les
collègues britanniques dans le parlement
aux pleins ils ont une voix singulière
qui compte nous oblige à être
intelligence c'est intéressant de
débattre je vous le dois pour les
travailler c'est le cas même même pour
les conservateurs mais en même temps
faut se rendre à l'évidence la situation
politique a changé et rien ne serait
pire qu'une réponse à petit pas et
techno là où on a quand même besoin
maintenant de retrouver du jeu politique
merci à eux les hangars je veux bien que
vous riez une décision politique des
deux mâles et les députés britanniques
ne siège plus au parlement européen il
ya plus de commissaire européen à la
commission européenne
c'est mais est-ce que c'est illégal
parce que pour l'instant mais pour
l'instant voilà ils ont horizon arrivé
comme le peuple a tranché il ya en effet
on peut commencer à discuter si vous
voulez mais rien ne se fera de manière
approfondie tant qu en effet cette
lettre n'aura pas été envoyés et donc
deux ans et demi minimum c'est à dire
que pendant deux ans le royaume uni est
encore membre de l'union européenne tout
en étant en train de sortir je reconnais
que c'est à peu alors trop bien et puis
c'est une première en fait dans l'union
européenne mais alors merkel mettent en
garde contre des réactions trop rapide
et simpliste un des 27 philippe g20 bien
sûr mais il ne faudrait pas que l'on
maintenant commence à finasser mais
parce que et les britanniques qui sont
qui ont décidé de sortir et des
européens qui assistent au spectacle ne
veulent pas se retrouver dans une
situation pendant plusieurs mois rien va
se passer il ya une décision qui est
prise il faut l'assumer
vous avez absolument raison de dire que
juridiquement il ya un flou majeur
puisque les textes ne sont pas aussi
contraignant que ça met les textes
permettent d'avoir un traité de divorce
qui s'écrivent en deux ans ou moins
rien n'interdit au loin sans - ou plus
verte à dire que si tout le monde est
d'accord les 28 états auraient été les
27 restants sont d'accord ils peuvent
donner plus que deux ans pour écrire
nous de notre famille politique le ppe
m'appelle les conservateurs n'ont pas
britanniques mais les consommateurs ou
les démocrates chrétiens au pas au
parlement européen nous sommes tout à
fait opposés à une situation
d'incertitude à l'arc
ira aussi aller justement eux bridge et
bar à ce propos françois hollande c'est
donc bien entendu exprimer à cette
question le voit des prix identiques
mais gravement l'europe à l'épreuve et
on attend beaucoup de la parole
française et franco-allemande bien
entendu il ya une réunion qui est prévue
ce lundi à berlin avec matteo renzi et
donald de tout ce qu'on écoute le
président de la république
le danger est immense face aux
extrémismes et au populisme
il faut toujours moins de temps pour
défaire que pour faire pour détruire que
pour construire la france pays
fondateurs de l'europe ne l'acceptera
pas un sursaut est nécessaire l'europe
pour aller de l'avant ne peut plus faire
comme avant
les peuples attendent de l'union
européenne qu'elle réaffirme ses valeurs
valeurs de liberté de tolérance et de
paix c'est l'histoire qui frappe à notre
porte
ce qui se joue c'est la dilution de
l'europe au risque du repli ou la
réaffirmation de son existence au prix
de changements profonds
je ferai tout pour que ce soit le
changement profond plutôt que le repli
et la france a une responsabilité
particulière parce qu'elle est au coeur
de l'europe parce qu'elle a voulu
l'europe
pascal a bâti l'europe parce qu'elle est
le pays qui peut entraîner les autres et
qui est garant de l'avenir de notre
continent
alors justement juncker a réaffirmé la
nécessité d'une initiative de moteur
franco-allemand ainsi qu'angela merkel
on les écoute
j'attends du moteur franco-allemand des
prises de positions très est clair je
voudrais que pour tout le monde il soit
clair évident nécessaire qu'il processus
d'incertitude dans lequel nous on entre
et ne durera près qu'à trop longtemps il
faut accélérer les choses
est-ce que petit drôme aujourd'hui
représente une pause dans l'histoire
européenne
une pause dans le processus
d'intégration européenne
les conséquences dépendront de
l'attitude des 27 autres états membres
qui devront être capables de tirer des
conclusions du vote britannique qui ne
seront pas précipité simpliste car cela
diviserait un peu plus l'europe alors en
gros là on est vraiment dans une
séquence qui s'ouvre c'est changer
l'europe où la voir mourir mais en même
temps j'ai eu envie de vous dire ça date
pas du bric site
juncker lui même qui parfois est
inspirée avait dit ma commission c'est
celle de la dernière chance
encore une fois le break si ce n'est par
exemple pas les crises à l'époque ça
n'est rien d'autre que la conclusion
d'une séquence de crise qui dure depuis
des mois
donc de toutes façons bien sûr va
falloir changer on parle beaucoup
d'initiative franco-allemande moi
j'aimerais déjà qu'on prenne
l'initiative française
ce que le problème des initiatives
franco allemandes dès le départ c'est
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps de discuter
franchement avec notre partenaire
principal en l'occurrence madame merkel
sur ce qu'on veut pour l'europe
j'espère en tout cas moi je disais déjà
en 2002 il aurait dû renégocier le tcg
c'est un peu le péché originel
je suis de gauche je les soutenais j'ai
voté pour lui mais je le regrette mais
c'est pas trop tard et l'a clairement où
dit il faut que la france sache qu'elle
veut la france à mon avis ce qu'elle
doit dire c'est que plutôt que une sorte
de fuite en avant que constituerait une
sorte de saut fédéral on sait pas trop
pourquoi d'ailleurs il faut dire on est
sur l'intervention il faut que l'europe
des projets il ya des grands projets qui
nous tiennent à coeur des choses qu'on
peut faire qu'on peut faire maintenant
prendre un exemple quand même qui donne
une image navrante de l'europe la france
et l'allemagne s'étaient engagées sur la
taxe sur les transactions financières
droite et gauche confondues on avait dit
c'est la taxe tobin à l'époque
voilà quelque chose qui est important ce
à réguler un peu les places financières
sa prime ça permet d'abonder le budget
européen kerecki qui puis finalement
cette coopération renforcée qu'il est à
15 puis à 11
là on arrive à 9 les pays comment ça a
traîné des pieds on va pas le faire leur
était un formidable
faisons le deuxième exemple la
commission de nounous condamne ou
français parce qu'on a décidé que les
transporteurs routiers
qui est ce qu'on leur a imposé de passer
les transporteurs routiers au smic
la commission nous dit attention vous
allez à l'encontre des textes européens
ça c'est franchement c est en train de
rome
non moi je en train de faire la bataille
sur le contenu le contenu et si vraiment
on veut que les gens aient envie
d'europe par faut leur donner des
preuves que l'europe
hazard va dans leur sens sénart bataille
s'est divisée dira merkel qu'est ce
qu'on peut proposer comme scénario pour
demain à d'abord il faut un pilote dans
l'avion il n'y a pas de pilote
aujourd'hui
hollande n'est pas un pilote hollande
est absent moi je suis effaré d'abord
vous l'avez entendu en réalité n'a rien
dit il a dit oui c'est grave attention
oui pour ça merci
il faut pas être président de la
république pour le dire moi je suis
effaré du fait qu'on arrive aux briques
site on se réveille ce matin avec la
gueule de bois on se dit au fond est-ce
que les grands dirigeants européens
avaient pris des positions fortes pour
tenter d'éclairer après tout le peuple
britannique non le la première fois que
le président de la république française
a parlé du bric site c'était il ya trois
semaines en inaugurant un tunnel en
suisse un tunnel en suisse il a fait une
déclaration
il faut le faire imaginez quand la
grande bretagne a voulu entrer dans la
communauté économique européenne à
l'époque il ya eu dix ans de débats en
france général de gaulle était président
de la république qui a eu des débats
passionnés dans la classe politique
française
le président de république française n'a
pas évoqué la question du bric site
avant que le brésil ait lieu alors je
vous renvoie pas par hasard à
l'assemblée nationale ce mercredi à une
séance de questions au gouvernement qui
était dédiée à l'europe
pardon mais toute la classe politique
française dans ce cas n'est pas à la
hauteur du débat sur l'europe ce que
vous êtes président de la république
vous êtes en charge d'un intérêt
supérieur c'est celui de faire en sorte
que la voix de la france pèse en europe
papon forcément défend des intérêts
français mais parce que il n'y a pas
d'europe s'il n'y a pas de moteur commun
franco-allemand
or depuis que françois hollande est
président de la république pardon il n'y
a plus il ya un effacement de la france
tel qu'il n'y a plus de moteur franco
allemand
donc la première chose à faire c'est ce
que juncker a dit il ya 10 messieurs les
français messieurs les anglais et
messieurs les ebrel et les britanniques
et
non madame l'allemande en liqueur
mesdames et chaussures mettez vous
autour de la table et de nous alors
directement
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait une
europe sociale est ce qu'on sort de
l'europe hémiplégique qui est donc le
marché unique est forcément un manque
d'harmonisation fiscale à manque
d'harmonisation sociale pied cette
demande parfois aussi de protection mais
qu'on attend de la part de génieau on
n'a pas eu de mort mais bon alors ce
qu'elle joue d'abord moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord n'y a pas de aussi l
europe 1 va mal aujourd'hui
alors pas avant le brésil temps c'est
parce qu'en effet le tandem
franco-allemand marche mal voilà et on
sait que l'allemagne ne peut pas prendre
des initiatives tout seul parce que ça
renvoie à un passé assez douloureux de
son histoire
donc elle a besoin que la france soit un
petit peu l'agitateur d'idées et je
rejoins philippe juvin là-dessus c'est
que en effet depuis quatre ans on n'a
pas vu beaucoup d'agitation d'idées de
la part du président de la république
alors ils décident aujourd'hui dans un
élan j'allais dire un peu tardif de dire
je vais aller à l'émotion aussi les
moments et à berlin lundi discuter avec
la chancelière et pour dire oui pour
parler de quoi
parce que vous avez parlé la taxe
foncière moi je me souviens qu'on
pouvait aussi parlé de la fiscalité
entre la france et l'allemagne d'essayer
de voir dans quelle mesure les deux pays
qui sont les moteurs de l'union
européenne qui sont les deux tiers de la
zone euro les deux premières puissances
delà de l'europe puisse en effet ne plus
se faire concurrence sur des bases
différentes mais en effet harmonisée
c'est concret et c'est ce genre de
choses qu'il faut qu'on essaye de mettre
alors ça peut être dans la fiscalité ça
peut être dans d'autres domaines
il va bien falloir qu'on essaie aussi de
faire des choses avec les allemands en
matière de défense puis les anglais vont
avoir offert mais ils ont déclaré en
fait qu'il continuerait dans le cadre de
l'otan oui mais ça c'est une autre
affaire une autre affaire et à la
défense européenne il ya neuf lots dont
il sait des choses concrètes et je
rejoins ce que vous avez dit c'est comme
ça que l'europe à marcher depuis showman
on prend un problème on fera en prend au
projet on le mène à bout de manière
concrète ça fait un petit pas ouais mais
tu sais pas mais l'examen imaginez on me
concentrer les contours de la zone euro
drogué le premier pas entraînements et
on commence par ça et on continue les
autres vous avez qui veulent nous
rejoignons vont ils s'en prennent
suivront la mort 1
encore une fois à arrêtons sur
l'histoire du couple franco allemand
c'est très important qui marche mais
d'abord il faut déjà qu'on s'explique
avec les partenaires allemands
on donne l'impression qu'on veut la même
chose c'est pas vrai donc assumer en
même temps qu'on veut pas la même chose
essayons de mettre sur la table la sur
la fiscalité la faut pas être injuste
pour une fois l'europe avance 1 on en a
on à voter des textes au parlement il ya
des ja il ya quelques semaines sur la
fiscalité des multinationales
le problème c'est que et l'asie un débat
droite gauche une partie de la droite
européenne ne veut pas d'harmonisation
de la fiscalité l'impôt sur les sociétés
ou la tva ça c'est un problème politique
parlons-en mais après sur sur quel
contenu on a une europe monétaire en
tout cas pour beaucoup d'entre nous on a
une politique budgétaire commune une
politique absurde mais les communes mais
en même temps sur le social sur fiscale
c'est la concurrence à tout crin c'est
la compétition évidemment les gens ils
se reconnaissent pas là dedans donc de
toute façon dans le débat qu'on doit
avoir avec l'allemagne avant même de
prendre l'initiative parlements de la
zone euro je ne sais quel encore avancée
institutionnelle faucon et 7 des basses
ce débat sur la priorité est faux que
nous français on est en entendant un
rapport de force je m'excuse c'est comme
ça que ça s'appelle l'on dise
ben voilà nous vers où on veut aller
voilà quel compromis on est capable de
passer mais on va pas renoncer à tous
sous prétexte qu'il fait il ya
effectivement aussi la question de la
gestion notamment de la crise migratoire
dombasle pauline peut-être qu'ils vont à
terme encore poser problème notamment en
france parce que là le risque 1 c'est
clairement l'effet domino marine le pen
s'est exprimée ce matin à ce propos on
écoute nous vivons un moment historique
hier le peuple britannique à voter
massivement sans ambiguïté au vu des
résultats pour sortir de l'union
européenne et par la reprendre sa
liberté deux peuples le peuple
britannique a donc apporté aux peuples
européens mais aussi aux peuples du
monde entier une éclatante leçon de
démocratie n'a pas cédé à la peur
il n'a pas cédé aux prédictions
apocalyptiques que l'on agite est au
dessus de sa tête et il a choisi une
voie de liberté que le système cherchait
à lui barrer et c'est également jean-luc
mélenchon qui a tenu à s'exprimer sur la
nécessité de réformer l'europe ou de
l'aquitaine on écoutait nous sommes dans
une situation d'échec de l'union
européenne il n'est pas moins évident
que cette situation comporte de nombreux
dangers qu'il faut juguler notamment
celui du nationalisme et de l'opposition
des peuples entre eux car c'est au fond
ce que l'europe aura le mieux provoquer
entre les pays membres de l'union
européenne
au fond si nous laissons les choses
allaient comme elles sont et comme elles
vont alors il n'y aura plus qu'une
alternative changer l'europe ou la
quitter et ce sera le message que
j'adresse aux autres dirigeants des
gouvernements européens l'europe pour
les français on la change our la quitte
christopher chanterai finalement devrait
limite vous remercier d'avoir ouvert la
voie c'est le résultat d'hier et ou de
ce matin c'était pas du tout parce que
beaucoup d'entre nous attendions mais
nous aurions beaucoup aimé avoir voix au
chapitre à participer avec la france est
avec l'allemagne à une sorte de
leadership tripartite de l'avenir de
l'union européenne je suis pas d'accord
et que ce que dit madame le pen ni avec
ce que dit monsieur mélenchon bien
entendu mais elle aura pour la quitter
ou réformés l'europe surtout pas que
c'était un peu la position
quelque chose finalement vous exprimer
n'oublions pas que le parti conservateur
était divisée en deux par set pinceau
afférents d'hommes et de tous nous tous
qui étions enfants en faveur du maintien
c'était pour que du royaume uni reste
mais mais
soit une force pour réformer les
institutions de l'union européenne
pas par simplement sur l'aller alors il
ya un sondage au doxa qui a été fait
pour i télé qui donne le fric site donc
la possibilité pour la france de sortir
de l'union européenne donc les français
seraient opposés à 64%
finalement c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle non mais je crois que en fait
la question pour nous français c'est pas
réformé l'europe ou la quitter
c'est je pense que si on réforme par
l'europe elle est morte voilà donc c'est
aussi simple que ça et elle est la seule
question qu'on doit se poser nous c'est
comment on fait précisément pour pour la
réformer et qu'elles soient plus en
résonance avec les aspirations
populaires
c'est à ça qu'on est là ce qu'on doit
s'atteler à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est finalement un peu le
constat d'échec aussi de françois
hollande qui devait réformer sur cette
europe en 2012 et qui aujourd'hui se
redonne un petit peu l'image est moins
sévère que françois hollande ça va
étonner certains de mes amis mais ça
m'arrive quand même c'est à dire qu'il
ya aussi des choses que la france a
tenté et a réussi le plan juncker doit
beaucoup à l'investissement
même si en terme de résultat c'est pas
encore ça mais l'investissement de
relance de l'investissement doit
beaucoup à l'investissement de la france
sinon si on était resté sur la position
allemande
franchement on n'aurait pas bougé grand
chose de ce point de vue là la france a
joué son rôle sur le je parlais de la
tétée la taxe sur les transactions
financières là aujourd'hui
la france continue à plaider pour cette
solution même si d'autres s'en échappe
donc faux faut être moins sévère mais ce
qui est vrai en tout cas c'est que moi
j'attendrais de la france qu'elles
portent haut et fort une vision de
l'homme qui donne du sens or ça manque
mais ça manque aussi finalement madame
merkel parce que elle à cette autorité
naturelle c'est la chef pour le coup
elle ces chefs du camp conservateur de
la droite européenne
mais quand on interroge sur sa vision sa
vision c'est plutôt celle quand même
d'une cour de discipline budgétaire ont
cédé par la règle des sanctions c'est la
version monsieur cheveux bleus en fête
est finie et c'est précisément ça non
plus dont les européens ne veulent pas
donc il faut trouver une excuse elle
risque en france philippe juvin est-ce
qu'il ya pas leur risque alors en france
est d'avoir un effet domino derrière
garde ville d'art aux pays-bas la ligue
du nord en italie
elle également non mais faire un art
assurément je pense qu'il ya un vrai
danger non seulement en france mais un
peu partout la vue en pologne récemment
effectivement si on ne met pas plus de
fluidité d'expression de la démocratie
je ne suis pas de ceux qui disent qu'il
ya pas de démocratie en europe tout ça
c'est de la blague c'est vraiment de la
blague et la démocratie en europe mais
elle ne s'exprime pas suffisamment bien
probablement trop de technocratie trop
de caricatures de nous-mêmes trop
d'autisme parfois si on ne donne pas un
sens à la hauteur fait européen en fait
nous sommes incapables nous les pro
européens de montrer en quoi l'europe
est un bienfait et elle est là la vraie
difficulté donc nous nous pensent depuis
2005 en fait les pro européens sont même
plus
rwanda nous nous pensons aux
républicains que simplement
effectivement s'il n'est pas si
rapidement il n'y a pas une initiative
franco-allemande forte sur laquelle il
peut être je me retire 2,2 points nous
disparaîtrons collectivement et
honnêtement je le dis à mes amis
souverainiste qui croient qu'ils croient
comme moi en la grandeur de la france
la france ne sera grande que si elle a
un véhicule de puissance et une france
solidaire
elle n'est pas puissant tel n'est pas
souveraine la souveraineté s'exprime
parce que nous sommes justement unis
alors c'est quoi la refondation de
l'europe que nous croyons absolument
indispensable c'est d'un côté le marché
des 28 aujourd'hui les 27 qui qui qui
qui fonctionne bien c'est un marché de
libre échange mais ça ça ne donne pas un
sens et derrière un certain nombre de
nations sur la base volontaire vont
accepter d'être plus intégrée en matière
monétaire
un trésor européen des eurobonds
européen
une captation parlements de la zone euro
pourquoi pas une capacité à agir enfin
les crises asymétrique une politique
d'immigration que commune avec une
politique d'asile identique une
politique de l'énergie commune quelques
pas beaucoup quelques compétences
européennes extrêmement partagées et
mise en commun quelque part pas beaucoup
il faut qu'il la lisibilité et là on
redonnera un sens à ce qu'est l'europe
presque gens là vous êtes d'accord
oui tout à fait mais que n'at-on pas
fait plus tôt
enfin ce que parce que vous vous dites
le référendum en 2005
moi j'ai l'impression quand même que
depuis le traité de maastricht chez la
création de la zone euro
il ya eu des petites choses bien
évidemment il n'y a pas eu de grand
souffle et la fota qui pas monsieur
juncker son prédécesseur ou sont à 90 et
prédécesseur à tous ceux qui sont
suffisait à l'elysée à la chancellerie
allemande au 10 downing street à la
moncloa à dire les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement quand ils se réunissent
n'arrive pas à faire aboutir une volonté
politique commune pour aller dans une
direction et c'est ça qui fonctionnait
aussi aujourd'hui par les européens
parce que les députés européens il
travaille en effet etc ils font le
travail législatif
mais il ça c'est pas le parlement
européen qu'elle ait une telle
initiative donc il faut bien que ce soit
ceux qui sont en état de décider qui met
sur la table un projet qui disent on est
d'accord pour aller dans ce sens là on a
bien vu que là depuis 3 4 ans 20 depuis
la crise on a toujours réagi
un petit peu au dernier moment commenter
l'actualité en disant ah il ya un drame
et on n'a pas imaginé que les choses
allaient pouvoir se faire et donc on est
un peu dans l'urgence alors ça a été
vrai pour la crise économique et la
grèce un état qui fait défaut c'était
vrai pour l'immigration pathétique
pathétique on dit on dit la commission
fait quelque chose a commencé quelque
chose et puis et puis après les états
retire le tapis en disant ah non non
c'est pas moi je fais pas comme ça je
refuse le quota wagner à la commission
européenne avait une proposition sur la
crise migratoire en fait que les états
on replace alors voila mais pardon je
vous trouve très sévère parce qu'il ya
eu durant ces 24 s avère déjà viré zeta
j'entends bien ceux qui n'ont pas été au
bout de ce qui est fait est fait mais il
ya eu depuis 20 ans il ya eu des moments
où l'europe existaient pardonnez moi
mais quand il eut lehman brothers quand
ya eu là oui ça c'est ma question
j'ai failli quelques semaines de
l'économie mondiale l'europe l'europe
était présente et a dit voilà le plan de
sauvetage ça existe hélas il ça avait du
sens voilà alors je ne dis pas
uniquement parce que nicolas sarkozy
présidait l'union
à l'époque je le dis quand même parce
que finalement le président de la
république française finalement mettait
tout son poids avec la chancelière pour
régler les problèmes
au fond les citoyens se disaient oui au
fond l'europe ce n'est pas parfait mais
ça sert à cannes alors justement
transition toute trouvée est ce que
l'europe comme le dit marine le pen sera
un des enjeux de la présidentielle de
2000 évidemment évident et une certaine
façon c'est normal monsieur tire le la
politique européenne c'est notre vie
quotidienne
je parle pas de nous par le montage on a
connu des campagnes présidentielles ou
l'europe mais c'est bien le dialogue et
vous le disiez tout à l'heure de la
séance de questions au gouvernement la
mercredi que finalement j'ai regardé sur
le conseil de certains de vos confrères
c'était quand même pas c'est quand même
pas flamboyant qu'on a vraiment
l'impression ou cesser dans ses textes
qui en a au ps mais en a aussi chez les
républicains ont fait un gros textes et
à la fin on dit et puis il ya l'europe
si c'était une sorte d'appendice revenue
aux républicains un rêve devenu répond
non ça franchement pas du tout envie et
chez eux aux affaires c'était pareil
mais il faut que ça soit au coeur de la
campagne européenne je reprends madame
sur un point qui se disent et les états
pas vous parler de la commission je
m'excuse je crois pas que monsieur
barroso faisait 13 ans vit un barroso
sûr car il faisait ne fait rien pour
contredire ton contre carrer les états
comme les états unis demandé rien n'y
faisait rien sans ses portes courant
revienne sur 2017 résister comment
est-ce que ça peut être commencer à
droite en tout cas au ski et le camp des
républicains
un certain nombre de candidats à la
candidature à la primaire un plus mais
les principaux ils sont tous fait un
discours sur l'europe tous j'ai les
textes donc si vous les voulez oublier
je viendrai j'ai lu j'ai pas trouvé ça à
gauche pour l'instant c'est à dire que
les candidats il y en a aussi plusieurs
me semble-t-il
mais même le présent la république ne le
dit pas ce qu'il va faire sur leur or il
est temps se faire aujourd'hui
alors il l'a dit en 2012 il l'a pas fait
donc on aimerait aussi que tous les
candidats alors on sait très bien là que
marine le pen et mélenchon eux leur
discours ça va être complètement
différent
marine le pen et mélenchon chaque fois
sur l'europe et 10 pas du tout la même
chose faut pas non plus faut pas sombrer
dans un an de caricatures l'avait
entendu mélenchon s'il vous plaît merci
beaucoup merci à vous malheureusement
c'est la fin de cette émission on aura
réussi téléspectateurs à vous éclairer
sur cette question bien entendu la
semaine prochaine vous avez rendez vous
avec nour nobel toutes nos tranche
d'information qui reviendront largement
sur cette question je rappelle le
calendrier
le président sera donc à berlin lundi un
sommet européen mardi mercredi ainsi
qu'une session extraordinaire du
parlement dans lequel dans la cage où
siégeraient bien entendu merci à tous
mardi matin merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi
et bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires ciao